well this is what it's like when your
show has money actually that made me
want to go to your show yeah absolutely
my set is the size of my current
greenroom in Europe you know what though
but that's awesome because it kind of
creates um if you've done an econ live
like it kind of creates this whole
atmosphere we're all together and it
creates like kind of ready for that's
like the knife suede that's a nice
disclaimer of being like it's small no
okay I'm being real because sometimes on
big huge sets they can feel a little
cold like our job was to warm it up we
wanted to warm it up but I actually
think that's really important like about
your show I think it it creates like
more of a like cozy kind of environment
to where you really get to like open up
well I appreciate that I do love it
don't get me wrong I do love it it's
just my guru memory Charlie oh yes last
time we saw each other we I think had
been like close to like a month because
we both started at the same time and
she's doing a great job and it was so
awesome to be starting at the same time
it really was and it was really nice to
talk to another woman oh it's in a very
similar position and just as texting
simply she's kind of like rah Harry
refreshing I remember texting you one
day and I was having a really
overwhelming day and I thought I bet you
Kelly could relate to this like picked
up the phone and I was like my one
friend whatever I was like hey how's it
going and we actually talked about how
we both just finished crying yes yes
that's it normal David and then we but
yeah then I was telling you how I had no
time to cry not to schedule ten minutes
to cry because someone kept knocking on
my door I was like I'm crying I think
because you came from YouTube right and
so what what would you say the
difference is like because all your
YouTube videos isn't going to now doing
the nighttime thing like how different
is that oh it's so different I mean on
my youtube channel I control everything
and there's a crew of five people yeah
that work on my content and then I got a
show and y'all there's literally 100
people yeah that work on my show there's
probably three thousand here but 100
work on my shows about the same and they
have all these jobs that I'm
be honest not familiar with me neither
someone will come up to me they'd be
like I'm your script supervisor and I'm
like and I'm like way to go scripts
needed supervision I know I like this
group so well done so many names yeah I
know I called one my friend
it is cool though how you have this
whole team that kind of supports you and
lately you know lifts you up in it and
make sure show really awesome oh I love
it I live in the crew late nights that
makes it so here's my thing with your
new deal your new life okay talk to me
have you blown any money on an
indulgence of any sort oh well you know
a lot of my life has changed except for
the fact that I'm very cheap and well we
consistent but there is one thing I
splurge on I feel like it's very
relatable though the one thing I will
splurge on is birthday parties for my
dog not yours
listen my birthday I'll be up in a
Denny's just over Miami recently turns
to I know pick up something I just
turned to Henry yeah when we're the same
yeah we're the salmon my dog turned to
and I gave him a Harry Potter themed
birthday
[Applause]
and he was at a place in dogwarts thank
you thank you I love Harry Potter as
well I mean it was great all the dog
friends came I made all these cupcakes I
look at him he's dressed as a Gryffindor
oh my gosh that's so cute that you spend
your money on other name totally I feel
like I have my priorities in check meet
you a minor difference I was like happy
birthday Henry Naugle
but you have an awesome connection with
your fans yeah and I mean and I actually
loved it about you know I think that's
why you're successful and what is like
maybe your most fun or coolest kind of
fan encounter I mean there's so many I
really do genuinely love my fans so much
I mean when you come from the digital
space you really understand that there's
no record label there was no one that
started except for people just
supporting you online so those
supporters are really responsible for a
lot of what I have and so I have so much
love for them but one of the most
meaningful stories I think you know
earlier this year when I came out online
I remember I was being I was really
scared and it was before I had a trip to
India
and you know Indian culture is quite
taboo when it comes to sexuality I was
so stressed going to India and I was
like oh what are people gonna think I
don't know and I had a meet and greet
and I met with 200 fans and honestly I'd
say about a hundred fans came up to me
to my face during that meeting great and
for me that was so powerful because one
I know how hard that is and I was like
wow my knee my knee for you I will not
stop talking until you subscribe to my
youtube channel that's right and I could
talk a lot seriously not gonna stop yep
still here not going anywhere I see you
don't walk away from this